my name is Becky and I have a dog named
Mable my name is echo and I have a cat
named mummy and we're going to be
swapping pets her name is Mabel monster
I've had her for thirteen months now and
she is about 15 months old I truly like
I'm gonna cry I love her so much she is
the sweetest snuggle monster in the
whole world really insists on constantly
being in contact with her human nope but
she's perfect she's perfect is she on
your shirt she's yeah she's beautiful I
have a cat and her name is mommy I
always say she's kind of like a teenager
okay
she's pretty to keep to herself I'm an
independent woman fair I both cat know
okay I just wanted to say goodbye
no she's too busy with the box oh my
gosh it's only three pages for - mine is
like a quarter of the okay so here's the
thing she needs a lot of attention so
there is a lot of information here she
is not a food motivated dog she'll go a
full day without eating cuz sometimes
she doesn't you have to hand feed her
the kibble she gets her teeth brushed
every night she has Paul bomb for her
paws to keep them soft and healthy
that's yeah I haven't walked a dog in a
while so I'm like a little worried I'm
gonna get like yeah you across probably
are my schedule is very short yeah I
generally just feed her in the morning
and then pet her and cuddle her when I
get home and then I feed her again she
kind of takes care of herself there are
times when I like I like try to be like
mommy let's play let's hang out and
she's just like don't talk to me don't
bother me so the whole video is going to
be me baby
mommy to love me it's possible I think
I'm gonna be the saddest living creature
participating in this I don't know why I
agreed to do this I think at first I
thought it was a joke
like as a joke I was like yeah someone
take my dog she's a lot of work
and now I'm like but that's all I have I
miss having a dog I love having a cat
and I love mummy I am a dog person as
well as a cat person
I also kind of miss the freedom that
comes with cats like I'm gonna run so
many errands tomorrow oh yeah well - but
still I'm gonna leave the house without
my dog on a Saturday for the first time
in a year I'm also gonna pee with the
bathroom door shut for the first time in
like a year and change does she not like
the bow yeah no no no yeah no that's
good yeah you're not gonna pee alone
sorry should have led with that
I love you it'll be okay you'll like
Becky you're not going to the vet you're
gonna be okay yeah are you ready I'm
gonna take off your leash okay Oh see
this is off to a great start
are you afraid to loop in Jana you will
eat in two ways good oh wow you found
another one okay come on I love you you
were my baby you'd be good okay
okay then I'm leaving you
[Music]
he's not here it's ok I'm here I'm your
friend
okay so Becky's gone and Mabel's here
I'm excited I'm excited I am just
nervous that she's not gonna like it
because I'm not Becky okay I have just
dropped off Mabel monster mummy and I
are in the car
I think she little frayed she might be
going to the vet so I'm hoping my
apartment is a nice surprise
I don't know what it means when cats wag
their tails do cats wag their tails when
they're happy that a thing oh my god are
you okay okay okay this is a lot put to
be honest kind of nice I don't know a
lot of snow
[Music]
okay I'm gonna let you look around while
I set up your stuff
deal okay so here's the other thing I
think I probably maybe sort of neglected
to mention I am just the teeny tiny
slightest bit allergic to cats
I'm gonna take some benadryl and we're
gonna have some fun yeah yeah so Becky
gave me this giant bag okay so this is a
goose toy your blanket I think a brush
okay this looks like a giant gumdrop oh
that's the bomb that she was talking
about apparently maple gets paw balm and
looks like your toothbrush and
toothpaste your pill they got food oh
that has food in it god bless your water
bowl this looks like our harness that's
a lot of stuff I'm not gonna lie for one
night that's a lust I feel prepared
[Music]
mommy has no interest in playing with me
right now so this is uh going well
she is buddy me Pat her lots of good
pets you definitely tell she's a little
nervous she's not sure what to make it
this place which is fair it's new and it
smells like dog she's not amused by my
bowl
hey people that's mommy's toy ok Mabel's
soul wanna mummy soy can I have that
back please
oh no we like that I told you those
mummies its Keita that's a feather
you'll want that yeah Mabel is just
taking all of the movies toys Oh mother
I'm gonna be going to press right after
this
[Music]
I have just been informed that a light
tail wag means you're probably annoyed
with me and based on your body language
that is probably pretty accurate so what
I'm gonna do
I'm gonna go take a shower and give you
the whole space to yourself to get comfy
and to relax and to explore and figure
out what you need sound good okay see by
maple it's just us now oh it's okay I
just joking okay it's fine it's fine
people really liked Ryan and now write
it as well it's okay
cats mummy has found her place to hide
for the evening I don't know how she got
there
I don't know how we're going to get her
out if we're ever gonna get her out ah
yep I moved the couch up just a little
I'm not gonna force her out but I want
her to be able to get out if she so
chooses and I don't even know how she
fit back there but mummy is alive and
well and just stealing hiding behind
again so that is where we're gonna let
her be for a little bit excuse me that's
my couch
hello I was recently talking to one of
my friends who is a cat owner she told
me that dogs tend to attach to people
and cats tend to attach to places taking
mummy out of her home base might be
setting her off a little bit which is
okay new places are scary
she only been here a couple hours I will
say this is not all cats I have had cats
come over and stay here I don't know if
cats do treats
[Music]
not
I've just showered and now I'm going to
do the night routine that Becky has for
maple
this is Becky's toothbrush and
toothpaste for Mabel Mabel has like
beautiful teeth you're fine right
am I going right I'm doing all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay that's actually mummys doing do you
pet a cat that won't come out from
hiding
mommy obviously wants to be pet
mummy just likes to make you work for it
he's gonna let them do their own thing
they can't let them some of you okay
mommy mommy I just want you to love me
so Mabel are you joining me in bed
mommy usually sleeps on this ottoman
right here I think she's sleeping here
tonight huh I've been told you're
snuggly all right good night Mabel I
[Music]
keep getting Logan up - meows meows it's
like 1:00 a.m.
and mommy has decided she has a lot to
say not sure what she wants me
but I think it's a good sign I don't
know I'm tired
here's now 2 o'clock in the morning
I've been woken up again to pet the cat
just wasn't expecting people gonna up
every hour for a pet but it's like
having Mabel here just a little louder
[Music]
at 6:30
I usually I'm sorry but someone is
[Music]
excited to see you too
[Music]
mummy spent all night meowing just
constantly meowing I'll probably Google
to see what that actually means y'all I
think this is a victory she is eating
and drinking that's all I can really
honest for at this point um this is a
first for me I'm gonna go run some
errands which means I'm gonna leave the
house I feel like I'm forgetting
something
cuz normally I get Mabel all set up for
her crate so she has a big old crate
there's water and a pillow and sometimes
their blanket I have this little device
which helps calm her down if she starts
barking a camera system so that I can
check in on her I normally have to leave
like a peanut butter or a calming filled
with peanut butter I don't you do that
the cat is just chilling still just
they're going back and forth behind the
couch I don't know what kids want I
don't know what cats need
I think the point of them is that they
don't really need anything right I
realize
this is really nice I will say though
like it is
much more work than mommy is much as I
really like you Mabel I do miss my cat
I'm getting firmly cold here okay you're
going over the rest hello
I have a dog
I know I see right it is maple
be strong
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Patito much anxiety less tourists you
were gone for like three minutes
you just spray
because she's gonna be get a lot about
okay
[Music]
like two seconds ago I'm not gonna lie
mummy this has been amongst the most
boring 24 hours mummys mommy is that you
pick her up in about an hour so mummy
has decided to emerge I don't get it it
don't fit she got a really brazen really
quick are you psyched I packed all your
stuff are you excited to go home yeah I
don't know what to tell you baby your
mommy's on the way I think the thing
that I've realized is that I at least in
the current moment current stage of my
life I have to have a cat because Mabel
is beautiful and amazing and a lot of
work I think this was successful I think
this was fun you are welcome to hang out
with me whenever well mommy's not around
cuz mommy I don't think with like this
has been fun
I'm coming to you mama oh yes we're
gonna let mummys mummy find mummy baby
[Music]
we've reunited yeah you're going home
with me
you didn't make Becky though I could
tell usually don't come out like that
silent treatment huh are you my sunshine
my only sunshine
yeah don't think I trade you in for a
cat or anything else another dog hamster
I don't want any of it just you just
perfectly perfect you
[Music]
[Music]